deutschland ist ja traditionell das
große geberland in europa und jetzt
hilft europa und die eu hat sich heute
auf einen gas sparplan geeinigt und das
in einer man kann sagen historischen
solidaritätsaktion alle mitgliedsländer
auch solche die gar kein russisches gas
importieren drosseln den verbrauch um
rund 15 prozent um ländern die von
russland besonders abhängig sind im
notfall aushelfen zu können ländern wie
deutschland
jetzt ist er fertig der eu gas
notfallplan die eu staaten haben einen
notfallplan zur drosselung des
gasverbrauchs auf den weg gebracht das
beschlossen die zuständigen
energieminister heute bei einem treffen
in brüssel das heißt zwischen august
diesen jahres und ende märz kommenden
jahres sollen alle eu länder ihren
gaskonsum freiwillig um 15 prozent
senken um länder wie deutschland welche
direkt abhängig sind vom russen gas zu
helfen der plan soll die risiken für den
fall reduzieren dass kreml tyrann
vladimir putin den gashahn nach europa
vollständig zugedreht ich würde gerne
noch sagen dass wir uns darauf
einstellen müssen dass
weniger oder irgendwann gar kein
russisches gas kommt sollte es anders
kommen werden überrascht sein aber wir
sollten nicht mehr überrascht sein dass
putin den gashahn zudreht dieser rat
heute mit seinem beschluss hat ein
starkes ein entschlossenes signal
dagegen gesetzt und ich denke das wird
auch in moskau gehört werden europa
lässt sich nicht spalten deutschland
muss sogar mehr als die 15 prozent
einsparen damit sollte putin den gashahn
zudrehen keine massiven probleme für die
industrie entsteht aktuell sind unsere
speicher zucker 63 prozent gefüllt vor
zwei jahren waren die speicher noch
knapp zu 100 prozent gefüllt um durch
den winter zu kommen braucht deutschland
wieder einen füllstand von 100 prozent
aktuell erhalten wir nur sehr wenig gas
aus russland allein nord stream 1
beliefert uns mit gas und das wiederum
aktuell nur mit 20 prozent der
gesamtmenge
heißt um den füllstand auf 100 prozent
zu bekommen muss deutschland richtig
hart sparen und auch wir privatpersonen
können mithelfen
damit sie mithelfen können beim gas
sparen brauchen sie nur zwei dinge tun
erstens der deutsche luft im schnitt
täglich sechs minuten dabei verbraucht
er jedes mal 3,6 kilowattstunden energie
für warmwasser
verzichtet man auf die tägliche dusche
und duscht nur jeden zweiten tag spart
man exakt 15 prozent zweitens jedes grad
und dass man seine wohnung stampa tour
senkt bringt sechs prozent einsparung
bei der energie reichen einem statt 22
grad auch 19 20 hat man also ebenfalls
15 prozent eingespart das gute daran sie
sparen nicht nur gas für deutschland
sondern ihr portemonnaie wird ebenfalls
geschont
ja also eine historische entscheidung in
und für europa heute sprechen wir
darüber mit dem geschäft der svp im
europaparlament manfred weber dvp das
ist so etwas wie die cdu/csu europas
herr weber müssen die deutschen keine
angst mehr vor dem nächsten winter haben
wir
müssen mit mit vorsicht und mit
schon einigen sorgen in den winter
blicken aber der heutige tag ist er
vergewisserung dass europa zusammenhält
und das ist es extrem wichtig wenn man
sondern die karuna zeit drinnen dann war
es in corona frequenz entschlossen haben
dass wir egoistisch waren dass
nationalismus in europa zurückgekommen
ist heutige tag kann dazu beitragen dass
das bei der gas problematik ist nicht
passiert wir gehen die herausforderung
gemeinsam an wie funktioniert denn
dieser sparplan jetzt wer mussten dann
sparen der start der einzelnen jedem
land oder die industrie oder die
bürgerwehr muss sparen
heute wurde beschlossen dass die staaten
der uci 15 prozent ein sparziel vorgeben
und das wäre eine massive am massiver
beitrag über den winter hinweg zu kommen
weil wir durch die gestiegenen
lieferungen aus norwegen aus anderen
ecken europas heraus russlands
russisches gas schon einigermaßen
kompensieren können insofern
wesentlicher beitrag heute mit diesem
ein sparziel aber die europäische union
ist zentralstaat das ergibt die eu auch
nicht vor wo es konkret beim gespart
wird oder bei der industrie das macht
die das land für sich selbst das ist
also berliner hausaufgabe jetzt konkret
die einsparziele in nationales recht
umzusetzen
jetzt ist europa ja auch solidarisch mit
deutschlandweit deutschland eben
besonders abhängig ist vom russischen
gas was können wir im gegenzug bieten
längere akw-laufzeiten zum beispiel naja
das ist eines der themen das uns als
deutsche abgeordnete auf europäischer
ebene entgegengehalten werden auch dem
motto wir sind ja solidarisch wenn
beispielsweise bei euch deutschen die
ihr so stark von russischem gas abhängig
sei eben die gasreserven zu ende gehen
dann wollen wir helfen aber als
voraussetzung müsst ihr deutsche schon
eure eigenen energiereserven voll nutzen
es gibt wenig verständnis in anderen
ländern dass wir deutsche kernkraftwerke
abschalten und gleichzeitig beim
nachbarn darum bitten dass er uns mit
gas unterstützt und insofern ist die
verlängerung der laufzeiten zumindest
über diesen winter hinweg eine absolute
grundbedingung darauf wieder die
europäische solidarität einfordern
können für die hoch halten sie die
chancen dass das dann tatsächlich auch
so kommt die abwehrfront bröckelt ja in
berlin auch die grünen als
koalitionspartner sind eher bereit jetzt
über die verlängerung pragmatisch
nachzudenken eine forderung von cdu csu
die sich jetzt durchsetzt und man muss
schon sagen noch vor zwei wochen wurde
in deutschland diskutiert das ging die
unmöglich im januar die laufzeiten zu
verlängern weil die sicherheit sei nicht
gewährleistet jetzt plötzlich geht es
mit der sicherheit insofern zeit gesagt
dass das ein vorgeschobenes argument war
gottseidank setzt sich jetzt
pragmatismus und nicht die ideologie
durch und ich muss als europapolitiker
schon auch sagen europaweit haben wir
entscheidungen die für die in richtung
kernkraft gehen in den niederlanden
werden zwei neue kernkraftwerke gebaut
in finnland mit unterstützung der grünen
der dortigen regierung werden neue
kernkraftwerke gebaut in tschechien wird
neu gebaut das heißt wir deutschen
werden uns mancher realität stellen
müssen und durch die ampel jetzt
schritt für schritt sozusagen erkennen
der realität
[Musik]